right outright and over in the
regulation is to go overtime because you
got guys out here that got some legs
they got a lot of miles on it
[Applause]
again sabonis playing with five fouls he
wants to go left
basically then faces did the right thing
they went out a double team
he likes he likes you going left that's
his thing
and you got to know that
james with his 4-3
and he's got some bonus which makes it
hard for him to close
because he can go around sabonis he has
hoses
he has matched his season high and
that's knocked away james made the
defensive play
he carried the ball
no question
discontinued dribble double dribble
carried the ball you call it what you
want
what what is lebron looking for
oh
somebody is
we got a fan that's that's
got a little unruly and lebron is
pointing it out to the officials
and what they're going to do
is they're going to put these put them
out
i don't know clearly i wouldn't know
what they said they're on the other side
of the court
but they're putting them out
[Applause]
listen we'd love for you to come to the
games please
but don't get yourself thrown out no you
know i don't think no one none of us
want you thrown out
but he went right to the official and
got
that couple thrown out
pacers down three this is the guy you
want to attack oh
myles had fallen and was trying to get
up
duarte's missed three straight after
hitting that game tying three to force
overtime